boa tarde bom grado o convite e esse
também é cara bahia falar sobre as
plantas e adoraria falar sobre esta
cidade também falar sobre o que me move
que me passa da capacidade foi diferente
mas daqui de aproveitar ao dade novela
tinha tanta gente está vivendo a era
jovem
alguns modelos de negócios novas coisas
desafiando o status como geral e essa
galera que tá fazendo coisas diferentes
e acaba aqui no palco do ted
falando para outras pessoas sobre o que
elas fazem ou sobre o que elas
aprenderam fazendo estavam fazendo é
legal falar dessa galera tipo a gente se
inspira muita gente a gente consegue
passar realmente os conhecimentos o
mundo adora falar sobre os fazedores
sobre a galera de capa de revista
mas eu tô aqui pra falar sobre uma outra
galera que é tão importante quanto quem
faz mas que não aparece tanto pra mim é
muito importante e eu queria dar um
pouquinho de atenção para essas pessoas
e dizer obrigado de certa forma sempre
existirão dois tipos de pessoas já as
pessoas que reclamam que as pessoas que
fazem ea proporção entre elas é mais ou
menos assim tem muito mais gente que
reclama do que é pessoas fazendo essa
galera que faz nessa linha vermelha
são as pessoas que cansadas de tanto
reclamar o cansado de tanto ouvir alguém
reclamando sobre determinado assunto se
levantar da cadeira propuseram uma
mudança e fizeram algumas pessoas que
colocaram seu na reta botar a cara a
tapa
propuseram uma mudança por 1 a 0 essas
pessoas se levantando essas pessoas que
fazem
e essa bola branca essa enorme máxima
bola branca são as pessoas que reclamam
todo mundo tem um amigo ou familiar um
conhecido no facebook não pára de
reclamar sobre tudo isso é política
sobre economia sobre a cultura sobre
enfim a fila do mercado
o engarrafamento sobre o preço do pastel
sobre o jogo de ontem sobretudo nessa
galera que reclama a la constantemente
está abastecendo as pessoas que fazem
com insights de coisas pra fazer né
porque essas pessoas que reclamam são
excelentes em observar o mundo como
parece anterior estava mostrando essas
pessoas conseguem olhar os micro
detalhes e sobretudo então essa galera
reclama é importante porque elas dão um
insight
mas elas sozinhas fazem nada elas
sozinhas não empurrou pra frente quem
por um mundo pra frente quem faz mas é
não é de hoje que eu percebo o
nascimento de uma nova categoria de
pessoas
pra mim é muito importante e que a gente
talvez não consiga encaixar entre
pessoas que reclamam que seus fãs não é
a cara que reclama não quero que faz são
as pessoas que apoiam quem faz e a gente
chama essa galera de tantos a terceiros
são pessoas que tipo resolveram pegar
parte do salário delas para apoiar
projetos de outras pessoas
são pessoas que resolveram pegar o tempo
de trabalho delas para apoiar projetos
de outras pessoas
são pessoas que pegaram o seu
conhecimento para projetos pelas pessoas
então por exemplo uma chama carol ela
cineasta ela ficou o tempo inteiro
viajando produzindo longas metragens
curtas metragens é o tempo inteiro
fazendo a vida profissional dela crescer
só que ao chegar a mim fala acaba não
tendo tempo de me envolver com essas
causas sociais não tenho tempo de ir pra
rua fazer as intervenções urbanas
enquanto faz o que eu posso fazer em
várias formas de fazer alguma coisa
uma delas é apoiada já as outras pessoas
desde aquele momento ela começa a apagar
a ativa 130 reais de salário dela todo
mês a investir em projetos de
financiamento coletivo das pessoas 150
reais
a coisa são pelo menos três projetos a
executa o participar da execução por mês
então isso é muita coisa e ela fazedor
fazer dois simplesmente porque ela está
envolvida em outros projetos
mesmo indiretamente é luciano braga
também quero meu sócio e em paralelo à
todas as coisas que a gente já faz ele
tira toda quarta feira à noite ajudar
outras pessoas a tirarem projetos
parados no papel
então ele podia ter feito várias coisas
sabe o quão difícil é o quão complicado
é tirar a idéia do papel ele vai lá para
toda quarta feira à noite e ajuda as
pessoas a encontrarem alguns caminhos
pra executar essas idéias assim são
pessoas que não são fazedores porque não
estão lá todo dia meteu a mão na massa
mas seria injustiça dizer que ela não
tem uma parte fundamental em tirar os
projetos do papel
a beleza não é de hoje que os apoiadores
as crianças mas os amigos sempre foi o
p2
mas eles sempre foram os operadores
pessoas as pessoas estavam mais próximas
da gente então hoje eu vi algumas
histórias de pessoas foram muito
continuaram indo pra frente porque
tiveram pessoas apoiando o caso da
cerimônia de design dela assim não pode
parar agora vamos embora vamos fazer
merda taba do que algumas colegas graus
meus amigos dela professores para não a
gente tem que ir pra frente tem pra
frente tudo daqui pra frente
então sempre na nossa história pessoas
que estão nos apoiando a gente às vezes
nem percebe mas são pessoas que estão
dizendo sim a gente não tem idéia do que
um sim significa pronto mais decisão não
tem idéia de como o nosso sim na vida de
outra pessoa pode influenciar o futuro
pode influenciar o futuro da vida dela
por exemplo quando a gente
quando os meus amigos a gente resolveu
tirar um projeto local chamado que o
ônibus passa aqui é a gente apresentou
em 2012 oe2012 um amigo meu chamado
daniel larusso esse projeto o projeto
mudou minha vida de certa forma e
naquela época era só um desenho no papel
a gente explicou idéia pra ele colocar
isso é muito
vocês têm que fazer isso você tem que
fazer isso porque a cidade precisa
acontecer não sei se você se ligava a
idéia é muito interessante
se você colocar esse projeto no catarse
o seu primeiro apoiar e foi dito e feito
a gente botou o projeto catar sempre foi
o primeiro orador inscrito reais
então ele não tem idéia do que aquele
almoço a gente apresentou a idéia pra
ele o sim faz isso como aquele almoço
mudou esta não é o tipo de o tipo de
pessoa que eu chamo pessoas sim
são pessoas que têm a capacidade de
dizer sim motivar a gente aí pra frente
e se a gente parar pra ir mais fundo
ainda a gente vai perceber que todos sim
que a gente dá é um voto netinho todo
toda vez que a gente compra alguma coisa
está votando pela aquela coisa toda vez
que a gente escolhe se envolver com um
determinado assunto a gente está dizendo
que a gente tá apoiando assim a gente
vai ao shopping comprar um tênis de uma
loja de falar com ele escolhida a gente
tá vendo aquela marca de tênis que a
gente apoia aquela loja a loja no
shopping
a gente apóia a chapa está dizendo que o
estacionamento deixou o carro em que
após acionamento então todos sim que a
gente dá seja comprando seja abraçando
uma pessoa seja dizendo vai lá e faz
está apoiando essa pessoa não se a gente
parar por aí bem fundo nesse assunto eu
não gostaria de entrar muito funk
namorar horas
tudo que a gente faz está apoiando
alguém mas beleza voltando aqui mas deve
sempre ficar por perto
legal mas o que a gente faz com todas as
pessoas que queriam estar no nosso
projeto queriam participar do nosso
projeto mas estavam longe ou de alguma
maneira não conseguiu se conectar a um
fim à nossa causa nossa proposta o nosso
propósito com certeza existe essas
pessoas
mas o que fazer ou como encontrar elas
mas com o crescimento e fortalecimento
de algumas plataformas colaborativas que
têm aparecido pelo menos nos últimos
cinco anos
essas pessoas começam a se conectar mais
facilmente a cada vez mais fácil se
engajar numa casa cada vez mais fácil se
engajar no propósito
por exemplo hoje eu sou o apoiador da
simone uma das pessoas que apoiou o
projeto dela a adoção tardia porque eu
simplesmente fui pesquisar sobre quem
eram os palestrantes do pedex legal pra
na hora
então é difícil para eu fazer alguma
coisa sobre a cidade não sei nada sobre
isso não sei nada mas eu posso apanhar
eu acredito nessa causa e uma das
maneiras que eu posso te fazer é
aprender a pessoa fazer não só pra
mostrar rapidamente que algumas das
ferramentas que existem que pode ajudar
vocês apoiarem as pessoas então em
termos de provas fanning existe o
próprio fã do normal que é o
financiamento coletivo onde uma pessoa
falar com uma ideia de projecto
outra comunidade vai lá e contribuir
financeiramente com aquele projeto
acontecer tenho comprado foi recorrente
que há o próprio flamengo é é um gol e
assim o tempo inteiro acontecendo onde a
contribuição mensal de crédito todo mês
pinga lá r$10 e r$20 30 reais e tem
outros tipos de projetos projetos como o
rio mais meu rio do sangue
felipe tem várias ferramentas várias
plataformas são possíveis de vocês se
engajar em projetos outras pessoas e
participar daquilo mesmo que
indiretamente
sem falar sem falar nas milhares e
milhares não estava em centenas de
empresas institutos fundações editais
que existem para apoiar projectos de
pessoas
certo assim quem não apoia ou quem não
participa de alguma causa hoje não faz
porque não quer ou porque ainda não sabe
se vocês querem não sabiam que podiam
para a mais fácil
então essa só essas plataformas esses
sites na ala mais simples
esses sites eles existem de alguma
maneira para aproximar as pessoas
para aproximar essa galera que apoiar
quem quer fazer de uma forma é indireta
é das pessoas que estão fazendo
então é aproximar porque o que eu acho
que isso é importante porque eu acho que
é transformador
sinceramente acho que isso é essa
mudança de percepção é muito e
assim no momento que as pessoas querem
fazer sabem que existem pessoas que
querem ajudar
elas sabem que existe uma comunidade que
apoia unidade forte as pessoas que fazem
sempre mais confortáveis confiantes
seguros para fazer o que eu vou fazer eu
não sei muito bem como aquele projeto dá
certo
então por exemplo a benfeitoria que um
site de financiamento coletivo catarse
melhor a maior taxa de aprovação dos
projetos
são 80 opção dos projetos que entram lá
são aprovado ou são financiados são bem
sucedidos em 80% ou seja se eu colocar o
projeto lá significa que tem chance de
ele ser bem sucedido
então por que isso acontece acontece
porque existe já uma comunidade de
pessoas que decidiu ser apoiadores e
quando se tem um grupo que apoia grupo
de fazer do cresce quando o grupo de
fazer cresce tem mais projetos no mundo
onde as pessoas podem apoiar o software
apresenta seu time precisa só tende a
crescer
eu tenho razões para acreditar que é
possível transformar uma pessoa que só
reclama uma pessoa que apoia uma pessoa
que apoia pessoa que faz os projetos que
eu falei anteriormente que era o que nos
possa aqui com dólares falou vai lá e
faz
é um projeto meu que é
internacionalmente
criado já aparece em todos os canais de
tv falando já aparecia em todos os
jornais dando entrevista e aparece na
época como ativista digital do ano
ativista não sei que nem sequer lá foi
muito legal mas o que eu acho mais legal
é falar de todas as pessoas que não eram
as idealizadoras do projeto que assumir
nossa causa para elas foram na sua
cidade como o fizer então mais de 30
cidades participaram desse projeto
porque elas aderiram à causa porque elas
achavam que era importante para elas
ela se concordavam com o projeto porque
ela não concordava com o propósito da
idéia
essas pessoas apoiavam por várias razões
a primeira porque eu estava implorando
muito pelo meu pai meus amigos logo no
início e cara eu preciso de vocês
o primeiro círculo de apoiadores precisa
ser rápida que as pessoas que não me
conhecem
tenho é a impressão de que fossem mais
pessoas aprendam já possa também ninguém
quer ser o primeiro apoiado então meus
pais meus amigos sempre os primeiros a
apoiar a beleza a segunda eu quero
recompensa
então as pessoas que contribuíram
dizendo ah eu tô fazendo apenas o
projeto que eu quero adesivos
eu vou receber na minha cidade e eu
quero finalizar minha cidade até ser a
causa nobre tem várias causas da empresa
que terceira é porque o projeto ou a
causa é importante essa pessoa
importante significa importar quando a
gente se importa com alguma coisa
significa que a gente está importando
ela para dentro da gente se importa com
uma pessoa com 50 uma casa não se
importa é um projecto significa que o
projeto está dentro da gente
isso é muito de posse de pensar
porque quando a gente quando a gente
entende a o valor da palavra a gente
passa a aas preocupar diferente com as
coisas que passa a investir em energia
de uma maneira diferente com as coisas
que se informa que o problema não é não
fazer
o problema é só reclamar acho que tem
várias pessoas que não fazem porque não
tem tempo não conhecem sobre o assunto
longe estão viajando tem medo sabe não
tem coragem de fazer era beleza não
fazer nessas condições não acho que todo
mundo tem que ser um fazedor mas eu acho
que querem algum tipo de projeto que
acontece é s quer ver algum tipo de
projeto tem que estar na rua e não
precisa fazer ele está apoiando as
pessoas que estão fazendo
então as pessoas falam sobre um sofá a
beleza mas esse cara é uma vez o falho
não fazem ficar só lá dando lhe
compartilhando eu acho que o live
compartilhar
ele é um l é só a primeira etapa de uma
pessoa que se importa em um determinado
assunto
acho que é a barreira de engajamento ela
vai ela vai diminuindo sabe então as
pessoas que estão lá e compartilhar
talvez amanhã não estejam na rua talvez
amanhã eu esteja assinado uma petição
talvez amanhã esteja contribuindo todo
mês por uma causa talvez amanhã elas
estejam iniciando o seu próprio projecto
sobre aquilo então acho que é pedir
demais que todo mundo faça tudo o tempo
inteiro sabe eu acho que é pedir demais
que todas as pessoas sejam fazedoras o
tempo inteiro
acho que seria muito melhor se não fosse
fazedor de apoiador só para explicar
para vocês algumas coisas assim de de
números e para vocês verem como bizarro
é o financiamento coletivo nos estados
unidos
no brasil a gente tem 50 milhões de
reais apoiando a 6.500 projeto está mas
nos estados unidos são 529 milhões só no
passado de dólares quando 23 mil
projetos e das dessas toda essa grana 2
milhões e 200 mil pessoas apoiaram o
projeto 770 mil pessoas apoiaram mais de
de um projeto 70 mil pessoas já passaram
mais de dez projetos para mim mais
bizarra isso 1.125 pessoas apoiaram mais
de 100 projetos só no que está a ter só
no passado 1.125 pessoas operam mais de
100 projetos eu dizer que esse cara não
é um fazedor é um absurdo só o que eu
quero dizer com isso quer dizer que quem
apoia é tão importante quanto quem faz
quem apoia é tão legal quanto quem faz e
apoia é tão fácil
quem faz o que quer dizer com isso que
apoia foto quem apoia foto e é sério é o
meu sonho é que em breve ou muito em
breve todas as pessoas sejam reclamador
as apoiadoras e fazedores para que esse
ciclo não tenha três coisas a gente
saiba da nossa importância
como cidadão de reclamar de apoiar e
fazer
obrigado